[Musica]
nessuno comprende la meccanica
quantistica
richard feynman premio nobel per la
fisica
se la teoria quantistica è corretta ciò
significa la fine della fisica come
scelta albert einstein premio nobel per
la fisica 1921
la meccanica quantistica è magica a
daniel craig berger fisico teorico uno
dei massimi esperti di entanglement da
queste poche frasi si evince chiaramente
come la teoria quantistica abbia ha
scioccato molti fisici e soprattutto i
padri fondatori stessi della teoria
vedremo brevemente di capire il perché
intanto possiamo dire che la meccanica
quantistica è la teoria fisica di
maggior successo ad oggi e ha
rappresentato una vera rivoluzione
scientifica e culturale un vero e
proprio cambio di paradigma nella storia
della scienza la meccanica quantistica
spiega il comportamento delle particelle
nel mondo microscopico quindi delle
particelle elementari degli atomi delle
molecole ma
diciamo è stata la base di partenza
della maggior parte delle scoperte in
fisica nel ventesimo e nel xxi secolo e
anche a un ruolo molto fondamentale
nello sviluppo tecnologico
per esempio oggetti che noi utilizziamo
quotidianamente
come ad esempio questo oggetto qui i
nostri smartphone non potrebbero
esistere senza la teoria quantistica
infatti in questa teoria ha permesso
invenzioni come quelle dei
microprocessori che stanno appunto nei
cellulari ma anche nelle automobili e di
recente produzione chiaramente e ad
esempio anche le memorie a stato solido
quindi ha dato il via a l'attuale era
digitale e di fatto è il duo dei
principali delle principali fonti di
contributo al pil dei paesi
industrializzati
ma siamo solo all'inizio
negli ultimi anni la meccanica
quantistica si appresta a
portare avanti una nuova rivoluzione che
da origine daranno origine alle
cosiddette tecnologie quantistiche di
seconda generazione la più importante
delle quali è solo i computer
quantistici che vedete qui nelle
immagini vi sembrerà strano quello che
sto per dirgli ma sono abbastanza
convinto che nei prossimi pochi anni
diversi di voi utilizzeranno il computer
quantistico già oggi in molte università
e centri di ricerca i ricercatori lo
fanno quotidianamente per le loro
ricerche anche nel mio gruppo di ricerca
all'università di messina si utilizza
abbastanza frequentemente
nell'immagine vedere alberto mercurio un
dottorando di fisica dell'università di
messina che si sta interfacciando online
con un computer quantistico ai pm
bene vediamo di capire un attimo perché
i fisici i padri stessi della teoria
quantistica furono scioccati da questa
teoria beh perché diciamo la realtà che
racconta questa teoria se di realtà
possiamo parlare è molto diversa dalla
realtà in cui siamo immersi noi
quotidianamente nel mondo quantistico ci
sono onde che e in alcune circostanze si
comportano come particelle
abbiamo particelle che sono in grado di
attraversare barriere che sarebbero
impenetrabili secondo le leggi della
fisica classica quindi come se fossero
dei fantasmi e abbiamo oggetti che
possono essere sospesi tra realtà
differenti per esempio un fotone che è
un quanto di luce può attraversare
diciamo diverse traiettorie
contemporaneamente quindi due o più
traiettorie finché non viene osservato
nel momento in cui viene osservato viene
effettuato una misura andrà a
concentrarsi in un'unica traiettoria è
però in maniera assolutamente non
prevedibile da nessuna teoria da nessuno
algoritmo è questa in determinazione da
cui anche il noto principio di
indeterminazione di heisenberg è uno dei
tratti salienti della teoria quantistica
ed è proprio quello che diede più
fastidio ad albert einstein da cui la
famosa frase
dio non gioca a dadi che ricevette come
risposta da un altro dei padri fondatori
della meccanica quantistica niels bohr
ok non sei tu che puoi dire cosa dio
deve fare o non deve fare
decide da solo
ecco questo è un po ci fa capire
che la meccanismo notizia ci racconta
una realtà che è molto diversa da quella
quotidiana però come vedremo è una
realtà che è molto vicina a delle forti
analogie col nostro mondo interiore con
il mondo delle relazioni umane ma prima
di andare a parlare di questa cosa
voglio puntualizzare
22 cose che per me sono molto importanti
1 non si tratta ovviamente di pura
teoria ci sono le applicazioni
tecnologiche ma è importante sapere che
questi effetti straordinari magici della
meccanica quantistica sono stati
osservati e misurati in moltissimi
esperimenti molti laboratori in tutto il
mondo e il secondo punto è che è la
tecnologia moderna
sta estendendo gli orizzonti del mondo
quantistico nel senso che non è più
diciamo non soltanto le particelle
elementari e il mondo microscopico che
obbedisce a queste leggi ma oggi è
possibile realizzare sistemi quantistici
che sono anche visibili a occhio nudo il
che è estremamente interessante ma anche
corpo ancor più sconcertante per esempio
diciamo alla vostra sinistra vedete un
circuito superconduttore che di fatto è
stato realizzato per comportarsi
esattamente come due atomi che si
scambiano fotoni sulla destra e vedete
qualcosa di ancora più straordinario è
sempre una semplice forcina è un
oscillatore meccanico delle dimensioni
di un capello che è stato posto come un
po come fosse un fotone in uno stato di
realtà sospesa tra alex e cioè in
contemporanea questo oggetto durante le
misure in laboratorio era fermo e
oscillava la sua frequenza di risonanza
torniamo brevemente ai computer
quantistici è interessante sapere che
sono proprio i fenomeni più strani più
straordinari della meccanica quantistica
a rendere estremamente potenti questi
dispositivi un computer tradizionale
anche un supercomputer e se deve
affrontare un problema molto complesso
lo affronterà in sequenza analizzando il
problema passo dopo passo anche se oggi
un certo grado di palette
parallelizzazione è possibile ma è molto
limitata invece un computer quantistico
si comporta esattamente come un fotone
che poi in contemporanea a seguire monte
tretto e quindi affronterà il problema
come un tutt'uno quindi seguendo le
varie le varie parti
tutte insieme chiaramente potete
immaginare la la differenza di tempi di
calcolo che su problemi molto complessi
può fare la differenza tra un problema
che non ha soluzioni con l'attuale anche
con il supercomputer e invece problemi
che questa maniera possono essere
risolti anche i minuti e inter da questo
punto di vista e computer quantistico ha
delle forti analogie molto più del
computer classico con la mente umana
perché ad esempio in particolare
l'inconscio e è noto di essere in grado
di seguire contemporaneamente
moltissime strade e questo sta proprio
alla base della creatività
dell'intuizione della invenzione
artistica ad esempio sono tutti
meccanismi che presentano delle delle
interessanti analogie
tuttavia come sottolineava il fisico
teorico freeman dyson le analogie sono
molte molte di più e non sono solo delle
analogie diciamo che ci sono delle ecco
perché la fisica quantistica importante
anche dal punto di vista col culturale
perché racconta la magia anche del
nostro inconscio la magia delle
relazioni umane che possono essere
complesse possono avere più risvolti e
noi possiamo nutrire sentimenti anche
contrastanti nei confronti di un'altra
persona ad esempio ma si va molto al di
là delle analogie recenti studi di
biofisica
tendono a supportare anche se si
spogliano ulteriori conferme
sperimentali
l'idea che la nostra coscienza la nostra
mente di fatto
alcuni meccanismi fondamentali di
funzionamento si basino proprio sui
principi più particolari della meccanica
quantistica ad esempio vi è un campo di
ricerca molto attivo in psicologia che
va sotto il nome di quanto mission che
ha dimostrato che è il modo in cui noi
umani prendiamo le decisioni può essere
descritto molto meglio da metodi basati
sulle probabilità quantistiche rispetto
a metodi classici standard
io personalmente ho dedicato gran parte
della mia vita allo studio e alla
ricerca nel campo della meccanica
quantistica in particolare un segno
questa teoria agli studenti
dell'università di messina gli studenti
di fisica e svolgo da anni attività di
ricerca nel campo dell'ottica
quantistica in collaborazione con
diverse istituzioni internazionali in
particolare con un centro di ricerca in
giappone e da alcuni mesi però ho
cercato di allargare i miei orizzonti
proprio per tentare di comunicare a
quante più persone possibili la magia
del mondo quantistico
in particolare ho fondato un trio
artistico insight unitamente anni e due
a due miei collaboratori alberto
mercurio e danilo rovito e ciò cerchiamo
di utilizzare di esplorare nella nostra
ricerca artistica la fisica quantistica
come linguaggio artistico
in particolare sfruttiamo l'arte
digitale in block shane che è una
tecnologia abbastanza recente che ha
delle potenzialità enormi in campo
artistico in quanto permette di
certificare la
provenienza e anche il possesso
dell'arte digitale e permette di
estendere anche il concetto di arte
all'arte interattiva arte programmabile
per esempio è possibile avere opere
d'arte che si evolvono nel tempo opere
d'arte che possono essere modificare
dall'interazione con chi ne fruisce
diciamo con chi va a interagire con esse
il mondo in rapida evoluzione
estremamente interessante lo diciamo
l'immagine che vedete sullo sfondo di
questa slide
rappresenta è un pezzettino di un'opera
che abbiamo realizzato non ancora
diciamo imposta il globe shane ed è la
prima opera realizzata interamente con
un computer quantistico
quella che vedete qui adesso invece
un'altra opera che ha un proprietario
stata insegna in block chain e venduta
fa parte di un progetto atomico in cui
abbiamo realizzato diciamo le voci di
whatsapp in questo caso vedere la
neutrale
mediante simulazioni di ultrà
microscopia quello a quello che vedere
il risultato di 12 atomi posti su una
superficie metallica e le onde che
vedete ne sono onde di probabilità
quantistica e descrivono gli elettroni
che su questa scala anno pur essendo
particelle come vedete hanno un
comportamento
perfettamente ondulatorio
andando avanti questa è un video di
un'altra opera rappresenta la prima
scultura virtuale quantistica può essere
vista anche in realtà virtuale tra vede
smartphone come se ad esempio fosse qui
in mezzo a noi ed è possibile
manipolarla ingrandirla insomma fare del
surf su queste onde quantistiche
ovviamente in questo caso abbiamo
realizzato con
pochi atomi lo smile
infine vorrei farvi vedere un'opera di
cui siamo estremamente orgogliosi
realizzata in collaborazione con uno dei
massimi artisti
iper realisti al mondo emanuele
d'ascanio quest'opera cerca di far
visualizzare quella che è una frase di
del fisico carlo rovelli che ci parla
ancora una volta del mondo quantistico e
anche della relatività generale ovvero
il mondo è fatto di eventi non da mondi
non da cose e questo a sottolineare che
la realtà che noi percepiamo non è il
frutto di oggetti che alla fine a
livello microscopico non hanno una
realtà ben definita bungie interazioni e
ancora una volta questo ha profonde
analogie con noi stessi perché noi siamo
non esistiamo senza gli altri siamo il
frutto delle nostre relazioni con gli
altri
e infine vorrei concludere con un
osservazione alla fine ognuno di noi è
fatto di particelle elementari le
emozioni che percepiamo risultano dalle
loro interazioni noi ci auguriamo ritiro
personalmente ritengo che l'arte
quantistica serva principalmente
articolare questo messaggio
[Applauso]
[Musica]